that is why we've put at the heart of
the defense command paper the mission to
seek out
and to understand future threats and to
invest in the capabilities needed
so that we can defeat them because
in defense it is too tempting to use the
shield of sentimentality
to protect previous battle-winning but
now outdated capabilities
such sentimentality when coupled with
over-ambition
and under-resourcing leads to even
harder consequences down the line
it risks the lives of our people who are
truly our finest asset
it would of course similarly endanger
our people if we simply wielded a sword
of cuts
slicing away the battle proven on the
promise of novelty
without regard for what is left behind
old capabilities are not necessarily
redundant
just as new technologies are not always
relevant
we must employ both sword and shield
because of those of us in government to
defend the country
we have a duty to protect new domains as
well as continuing investment in the
traditional ones
but always adapting to the threat mr
speaker
history shows us time and time again
that failing to do so risky relevance
and defeat
as a threat changes we must change with
it
remaining clear-eyed about what
capabilities we retire
why we are doing things and how they
will be replaced
the prime minister's vision for the uk
in 2030 sees a stronger more secure
prosperous and resilient union better
equipped for a more competitive age
as a problem-solving and burden-sharing
nato a nation
with a global perspective to become so
requires britain's soft and hard power
to be better integrated in this more
competitive age a golden briton has no
choice
but to step up ready to take on the
challenges and shape the opportunities
of the years ahead alongside our allies
and friends
let us be clear the benefits and
institutions of multilateralism
to which we have all become so
accustomed are an extension
not an alternative for our shared
leadership and our hard power
uk diplomacy should work hand in hand
with the uk armed forces abroad
and we will invest in our defence
diplomacy network
in order to strengthen the influence we
can bring to bear
and at this point mr speaker i wish to
pay tribute to all
our civil servants in the department and
further afield
in defence whose professionalism and
dedication
is every bit as vital to uk security as
all the other component parts of the
defense enterprise
likewise in the past we've been too
tempted to fund equipment
at the expense of our service
personnel's lived experience
that is why over the next four years we
will spend 1.5 billion pounds on
improving
single living accommodation and 1.4
billion on wrap-around child care
over the next decade the government's
commitment to spending 1.1
188 billion pounds on defense over the
coming next four years
an increase of 24 billion or 14 percent
is an investment in the prime minister's
vision of security and prosperity in
2030.
previous reviews have been over
ambitious and underfunded
leaving forces that were overstretched
and under-equipped
this increased funding offers defense an
exciting opportunity
to turn our current forces into credible
ones modernising for the threat to the
2020s and beyond
and contributing to national prosperity
in the process
it marks a shift from mass mobilization
to information age
speed readiness and relevance for
confronting the threats of the future
these principles will guide our doctrine
and our forced development
the integrated operating concept
published last year
recognizes that changes in the
information political environments
now impact not just the context but
conduct of military operations
the notion of war and peace as binary
states have given way to continuum of
conflict
requiring us to prepare our forces for
more persistent
global engagement and constant
campaigning
moving seamlessly from operating to war
fighting
if that is required the armed forces
working with the rest of government
must think and act differently they will
no longer be held as a force of last
resort
but become a more present and active
force around the world
our forces will still be able to war
fight as their primary function
but they also will have a role to play
before and after what we
traditionally consider as war whether
that is supporting humanitarian projects
conflict prevention and stabilization
or united nations peacekeeping
but technological proliferation mr
speaker
use of proxies and adversaries operating
below the threshold
of open conflict means that the united
kingdom must also play a role
in countering such aggressive acts
so the steps to sustaining uk leadership
in defence
must start with ensuring we are credible
and truly threat orientated
organization we must do so in
conjunction with our allies and friends
these reforms today will ensure that we
continue to meet our nato commitments
on land and enhance our contributions at
sea
as the second biggest spender in nato
and a major contributor across all five
domains we have a responsibility to
support the alliance his own
transformation
for this more competitive age so today
i'm setting out in this defence command
paper
the threats we are facing our operating
concept for countering them
and the investments in our forces that
are required to deliver the nation's
defenses
that threat demands that we make the
following investments and adjustments to
the services
we have been a maritime nation for many
many
centuries mr speaker and it is vital
that we have a navy that is both global
and powerful the royal navy because of
our investment in the type 26
type 31 and type 32 will by the start of
next decade have over 20 frigates and
destroyers
we will also commission a new multi-role
ocean surveillance ship
which will protect the integrity of the
uk's maritime zones
and undersea critical national
infrastructure
we will deploy new automated mine
hunting systems
which will replace the sand down and
hunt classes as they retire through the
decade
the interim surface-to-surface guided
weapon will replace the typhoon missile
and we will upgrade the air defense
weapon system on our type 45 to better
protect them
from new threats we will invest further
to implement the availability of our
submarine fleet
and start development of the next
generation of subsea systems
for the 2040s the royal marines will
develop from being an
amphibious infantry held at readiness
to a forward-based highly capable
maritime for future commando force
further enabled by the conversion of a
bay class landing ship
to enable literal strike
our land forces have been for too long
deprived of investment
and that is why over the next four years
we will spend 23 billion pounds on their
modernization
the british army will reorganize into
seven brigade combat teams
two heavy one deep strike one air
maneuver
and two light plus the combat aviation
brigade
in addition a newly formed security
force assistance brigade
will provide the skills and capabilities
to build the capacity of partner nations
in recognition of the growing demand to
enhan for
enhanced assistance and our commitment
to delivering resilience to those
partners
we will establish an army special
operations brigade
built around the four battalions of the
new ranger regiments
this new regiment will be succeeded from
one royal scots
two prince of wales royal rifles second
italian duke of lanks
and fourth battalion the rifles
our adversaries set a premium on rapid
deployability
so we will enhance the existing 16 air
assault brigade
with an additional infantry unit
supported by upgraded apache attack
helicopters
together they will create a global
response force for both crisis response
and warfighting the third division will
remain the heart of our war fighting
capability
leading in nato with two modernized
heavy brigades
in order to ensure we are more lethal
and better protected they will be built
around a modern
armored nucleus of 148 upgraded
challenger 3 tanks
ajax armored reconnaissance vehicles and
the accelerated introduction of boxer
armored personnel
carriers as i have repeatedly said
recent lessons from conflict in libya
syria and the caucasus
have shown the vulnerability of armor so
we will increase both manning and
investments in electronic warfare
regiments
air defense air defense and uncrewed
aerial surveillance systems
all complemented by sense offensive
cyber capabilities
the army's increased deployability and
technological advantage will mean that
greater effect
can be delivered by fewer people i've
therefore taken the decision to reduce
the size of the army
from today's current strength of 76 500
trade trained personnel to 72 500
by 2025. the army has not been at its
established strength of 82 000
since the middle of last decade these
changes will not require redundancies
and we wish to build on the work already
done on utilizing our reserves
to make sure the whole force is better
integrated and more productive
there will be no loss of cap badges and
as i've said earlier the new structures
will require fewer units
and therefore the second battalion the
mercian regiment will be amalgamated
with the first battalion
to form a new boxer-mounted battalion
to administer the new infantry we will
reorganize the regiments to sit in four
infantry divisions each will compromise
a more balanced number of battalions
and give the men and women serving in
them a wider range of choices and
opportunities
in pursuing their careers and
specialties in order to ensure that
there is a balanced allocation of
recruits
we will we will introduce intelligent
recruiting for the infantry
and each division of infantry will
initially feed the four new range of
italians
the final details of these
administrative divisions along with the
wider army restructuring
will be announced before the summer and
no major
unit deletions further will be required
today's raw air force is now deploying
world leading capabilities
p8 rivet joint a400m and the latest
typhoons
the f-35 the world's most capable combat
aircraft
is now being deployed to front-line
squadrons
in recognition of its battle-winning
capabilities we will commit to grow the
fleet between 48
aircraft the e3d sentry
two generations behind its
contemporaries will be replaced by a
more capable fleet
of three e7 wedgetail in 2023
these will be based on raf lossy maps
transforming transforming the united
kingdom
early warning and control capabilities
as well as contributing to nato
as the transport fleet improves
availability we will retire the c130j
hercules in 2023
after 24 years service 22 a400ms
alongside the c-17s
will provide a more capable and flexible
transport fleet
our counterterrorism operations are
currently supported by nine reaper
drones which will be replaced by
protectors in 2024
these new platforms will provide the
enhanced strategic isr
and strike capabilities that are so
vital for all our forces
all forces evolve and the increasingly
competitive and complex air environment
means we must set the foundations now
for our sixth generation of fighter
the typhoon has been a tremendous
success for the british aerospace
industry and we will seek to repeat that
with two billion pounds of investment
in the future combat air systems over
the next four years
alongside further development of the
lanka
ucav system we will continue to seek
further
international collaboration all services
recognize the importance of unmanned
aerial systems
which is why we'll also develop combat
drone swarm
technologies but in order to ensure our
current platforms have the
necessary protection and lethality we
will also upgrade the typhoon radar
and introduce spear cat 3 deep strike
capabilities
the lessons of current conflict mr
speaker demonstrate that however capable
individual individual forces may be they
are vulnerable without integration
u.s strategic command will therefore
invest 1.5 billion over the next decade
to build and sustain a digital backbone
to share and exploit vast amounts of
data through the cloud and secure
networks
to ensure our workforce are able to
exploit new domains and enhance
productivity
the command will invest in synthetics
and simulation providing a step change
in our training
the national cyber force will lie at the
heart of defence and gchq's offensive
cyber capability
and will base be based in the northwest
of england
keeping overseas informed of the threat
mr speaker and ahead of our rivals
means that defense intelligence will be
at the heart of our enterprise
we will exploit a wider network of
advanced surveillance platforms
all classifications of data and enhance
and analyzing
using artificial intelligence strategic
command will partner alongside the raf
to deliver a step change in our space
capabilities
from next year we will start delivering
a uk
built intelligence surveillance and
reconnaissance satellite constellation
space is just one area in which the
ministry of defense will prioritize more
than 6.6
billion pounds of research development
and experimentation
over the next four years these
investments in our future battle winning
capabilities
will be guided by the science and
technology strategy of 20 20 20
and new defence and security industrial
strategy published
tomorrow our special forces are world
leading
we are committed to investing in their
cutting-edge capabilities
to ensure they retain their excellence
in counterterrorism
while becoming increasingly capable of
also countering hostile state activity
to conclude mr speaker if this defends
command paper is anything
it is an honest assessment of what we
can do what we will do
we will ensure defense is threat focused
modernized and financially sustainable
ready to confront future challenges
seize new opportunities for global
britain
and they lay the foundations of a more
secure and prosperous united kingdom
we will for the first time in decades
match genuine money to credible
ambitions
we will retire platforms to make way for
new systems and approaches
and we will invest the most precious
commodity of all the people of our armed
forces
to serve my country as a soldier was one
of the greatest privileges of my life
serving to lead contributing to keeping
this country safe
upholding our values and defending those
who cannot defend themselves
putting yourself in harm's way in the
service your country
is something that fortunately few of us
are ever required to do
but we all have a duty to ensure that
those who do so on our behalf
are as well prepared and as equipped as
well as possible
so the success of this defense command
paper should not be judged on the
sophistication of its words
but on the implementation of its reforms
and ultimately
on the delivery of its capabilities into
the hands of the men and women of the
armed forces
it is they who keep us safe mr speaker
and will continue to do so
in the years ahead it is to them their
families and all those across defense
that we owe it
to make this polity policy into a
reality
the work to do has only just begun